>> Sean: PREVIEW OF
TUESDAY'S ELECTION SIX DAYS
AWAY.
MARTHA McSALLY.
U.S. SENATE CANDIDATE FROM
MICHIGAN JOHN JAMES IS BACK
WITH US.
U.S. SENATE CANDIDATE FROM
TENNESSEE CONGRESSWOMAN
MARSHA BLACKBURN.
GOOD TO SEE Y'ALL.
MARTHA, I'M LOOKING AT YOUR
RACE, ONE POLL HAS YOU TIED,
ONE HAS YOU UP.
I'M THINKING HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE THAT A WOMAN WHO
SAYS ARIZONA IS THE METH LAB
OF DEMOCRACY AND SAYS PEOPLE
IN ARIZONA ARE CRAZY AND
INVITES THE BLIND SHEIKH'S
RADICAL LAWYER TO SPEAK AT
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
SAYS IT'S OKAY FOR AMERICANS
TO JOIN THE TALIBAN WHILE
YOU HAVE SERVED 28 YEARS,
SIX TOURS OF DUTY WHILE SHE
WAS OUT ORGANIZING
PROTESTERS, AND I'M NOT
MAKING IT UP, WITH WITCHES.
HOW IS IT EVEN A RACE?
HOW IS IT EVEN A RACE WITH
THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA.
>> SEAN, IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
SHE IS CHUCK SCHUMER'S TOP
RECRUIT WITH A LOT OF MONEY,
WITH TV ADS, MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SHE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO FOOL A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOT AWARE OF THOSE
THINGS UNLESS THEY ARE
WATCHING YOUR SHOW.
I'M GRATEFUL YOU KEEP
BRINGING IT UP.
BUT THE ARIZONA MEDIA HAVE
BEEN PROTECTING HER AND SO
SHE IS COMING ACROSS AS
SOMETHING SHE IS NOT AND THE
BIGGEST POLITICAL MAKEOVER
IN OUR HISTORY.
WE ARE DOWN TO THE WIRE WITH
SIX DAYS TO GO.
WE CAN MAKE SURE WE SECURE
THIS VICTORY WITH SUPPORT
FROM PEOPLE ALL OVER ARIZONA
AND THE COUNTRY.
THEY CAN GO TO McSALLY FOR
SENATE.COM.
THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE WE WIN AND WE
NEED -- IF YOU ARE IN
ARIZONA, LOOK, I'M ASKING
FOR YOUR VOTE.
I'M ASKING YOU TO SEND OUT
AN EMAIL, DO A FACEBOOK
POST.
MAKE SURE YOU GET TO THE
POLLS.
TELL YOUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
THIS IS SO HIGH STAKES.
AND EVERY VOTE IS REALLY
GOING TO MATTER.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
ON EVERY FRONT.
JOHN JAMES, YOU HAVE NOW
CLOSED THE GAP 16 POINTS.
YOU HAVE GOT A RACE NOW IN
MICHIGAN WHICH, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
AS I SAID TO YOU, I'M SO
IMPRESSED EVERY TIME I HAVE
HAD YOU ON RADIO OR TV.
EVERY CAMPAIGN IS THE SAME.
DEMOCRATS YOUR SPONT IS
CHUCK SCHUMER IN MICHIGAN AS
ARE ALL THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE AGENDA.
THEY WILL NEVER SUPPORT OF A
PRESIDENT'S SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE.
THEY WANT THEIR CRUMBS BACK.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
SANCTUARY CITIES.
THEY WANT OBAMACARE.
HOW CAN DEMOCRATS BE RUNNING
ON THE BIGGEST MESS THEY
EVER CREATED?
>> WELL, DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
RUN ON IDENTITY POLITICS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO
IDENTITY.
THEY HAVE PIT AMERICANS
AGAINST EACH OTHER IN ORDER
TO KEEP THEMSELVES PROPPED
UP.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT MESSAGE
THAN I HAVE.
I DON'T HAVE A BLACK OR
WHITE MESSAGE.
I HAVE A RED, WHITE, AND
BLUE MESSAGE.
I'M A COMBAT VETERAN WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
I'M A BUSINESS LEADER WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO GROW
BUSINESSES AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY.
WE HAVE ENERGY ALL OVER THE
STATE.
WE CLOSED THE GAP FROM 26
DOWN TO 6 DOWN JUST THIS
PAST FRIDAY WE HAVE THE
MOMENTUM IN THIS RACE
BECAUSE PEOPLE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE CAN FINALLY HAVE
EXPERIENCE COMBAT AND
BUSINESS EXPERIENCE TO LEAD
US TO THE FUTURE.
LEARN MORE ABOUT OUR RACE
JOHN JAMES FOR SENATE.COM.
THE PRESIDENT CAME EARLIER
IN THE WEEK AND SAW THE
ENERGY AND MOMENTUM THAT WE
HAVE.
THE PRESIDENT ON THE UNITED
STATES ON THE INGRAHAM ANGLE
SAID THEY WOULD BE WILLING
TO COME TO THE STATE.
MR. PRESIDENT IF YOU ARE
WATCHING, PLEASE COME TO
MICHIGAN.
WE NEED TO YOU COME ACROSS
THE HUMP AND HAVE YOU
EXCELLENT LUCK ON ELECTION
DAY EVE.
WE WANT YOU BACK IN
MICHIGAN.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE EVERYTHING
WOULD WANT IN GOVERNMENT.
BUSINESS AND MILITARY
EXPERIENCE.
MARCIA, FIVE PROJECT VERITAS
TAPES HAVE COME OUT.
YOUR TAPE OF GOVERNOR
BREDESEN HIDING WHO HE
REALLY IS, PURPOSEFULLY
LYING TO THE PEOPLE OF
TENNESSEE AND HIS STAFF,
TURNED OUT BEING HIS STAFF
ACTUALLY REFERRING TO THE
PEOPLE OF TENNESSEE AS
IGNORANT I THINK TENNESSEE
IS ONE OF THE GREATEST
COUNTRIES.
SINCE THAT TIME IT SEEMS
LIKE YOUR POLL NUMBERS HAVE
GONE UP A LOT.
>> THEY HAVE INDEED.
AND WE LIKE THE TREND THAT
WE ARE ON.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THERE HAS
BEEN ONE SLIGHT AND ONE
DIMINISHMENT AFTER ANOTHER
FROM THE BREDESEN CAMP
TOWARD THE VOTERS OF
TENNESSEE.
THEY HAVE BEEN REFERRED TO
AS IDIOTS WITH AN
EXPLICATIVE BY A BREDESEN
SPOKESPERSON.
SAID THEY WEREN'T WORTH THE
TIME YOU HAVE HILLARY OF
COURSE DEPLORABLES COMMENT
AND BREDESEN FOLLOWING ON
WITH THAT AND THEIR
SPOKESPERSON'S MARK BROWN'S
COMMENTS.
HERE IS THE THING, SEAN,
TENNESSEANS ARE PRETTY
SPECIFIC WHAT THEY WANT IN
NEXT U.S. SENATOR.
THEY WANT A CONSERVATIVE.
THEY WANT MORE
CONSTITUTIONAL JUDGES.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEIR TAX
CUTS AND I CAN GUARANTEE YOU
THIS:  THEY WANT THAT
SOUTHERN BORDER SECURED.
AND THEY ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CARAVAN THAT IS
COMING THROUGH MEXICO INTO
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
EVERY DAY THEY SAY MARCIA,
WE KNOW YOU ARE GOING TO
STAND WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
YOU ARE GOING TO STAND TO
GET THAT WALL BUILT.
AND ABSOLUTELY, I AM.
AND IT'S A PIVOTAL ISSUE IN
THIS RACE.
>> Sean: I WOULD SAY MARTHA,
KAVANAUGH, CARAVAN, A LOT OF
THE RHETORIC OF THE LEFT HAS
BEEN SO OVER THE TOP.
AND THE ECONOMY HAS TURNED
AROUND DRAMATICALLY.
ARE WE BETTER OFF THAN WE
WERE TWO YEARS AGO?
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT US.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN
THAT I TALK ABOUT IN 2016
THEY ARE PERT
THEY BRE PERT
THEY BET PERT
THEY BETTEERT
THEY BETTERRT
THEY BETTER OFF.
8 MILLION FEWER PEOPLE ON
POVERTY AND FOOD STAMPS.
I LIKE AMERICA SUCCEEDING.
AND THE BORDER IS A BIG
ISSUE IN ARIZONA.
>> AMEN, SEAN.
I MEAN, I WAS AT A SMALL
BUSINESS CONFERENCE TODAY
AND THE OPTIMISM IS THERE
BECAUSE OF THE CONSERVATIVE
POLICIES.
WE ARE WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CUTTING
TAXES AND ROLLING BACK
REGULATION.
PEOPLE ARE BEING LIFTED OUT
OF POVERTY AND THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF GOVERNOR DUCEY
HERE, ARIZONA IS UP FOR
BUSINESS.
WE WANT TO KEEP GOING IN
THAT DIRECTION.
BUT, BORDER SECURITY IS A
BIG ISSUE.
THE TWO BASES IN MY DISTRICT
ARE NOW GOING TO BE STAGING
AREAS FOR THE MILITARY
COMING THERE.
>> Sean: OR PICK SOMEBODY.
>> WELCOME THEM.
>> Sean: PICK SOMEBODY THAT
THINKS ARIZONA IS CRAZY AND
LITERALLY THINKS IT'S OKAY
TO JOIN THE TALIBAN.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Sean: JOHN JAMES, DO YOU
KNOW WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IN MICHIGAN.
I HAVE BEEN TO DETROIT.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THIS
GREAT CITY WE VITALIZED
INSTEAD OF TALKING ABOUT
KNOCKING DOWN ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOODS TO CONSOLIDATE
SERVICES.
THAT CAN HAPPEN.
>> YOU MENTIONED PEOPLE
COMING UP FROM CENTRAL AND
SOUTH AMERICA WHO WANT THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
WHO CAN BLAME THEM?
THE THING IS SO DO PEOPLE IN
MICHIGAN.
SO DO PEOPLE IN DETROIT.
DETROIT HAS BECOME JIM CROW
NORTH.
DETROIT IS THE NUMBER ONE
MOST SEGREGATED IN THE CITY
IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND
SENATOR STABENOW HAS BEEN AN
ELECTED POSITION FOR 43
YEARS BEEN IN A POSITION TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT AND
HASN'T.
WE NEED TO BRING POSITIVE
CHANGE FOR EVERYONE.
DETROIT IS WHERE WE NEED TO
START AND BRINGING MORE JOBS
BACK TO MICHIGAN.
I CAN DO THAT.
>> Sean: MARCIA, I GIVE U.
THE LAST 20 SECONDS.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A
GREAT RACE.
THE MORE THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND TENNESSEANS ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT HAPPENED TO
KAVANAUGH, WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH THIS CARAVAN, WANTING
TO KEEP THEIR TAX CUTS AND
THINKING ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD
LOOK LIKE IF YOU HAD A
MAJORITY LEADER CHUCK
SCHUMER AND A SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI, THEY ARE RE-THINKING
THIS, SEAN, I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO DO VERY WELL ON
TUESDAY, NOVEMBER 6TH.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING WITH